welcome to this video part 12 of the pre
World Championship Series it's time for
game of the challenge of magnus carlsen
the world's number one and i'm going
back to 2011 the tournament in vacanza
in holland in the netherlands um Tata
Steel the current name of this
tournament and 2011 this was my camera's
finest hour when he won this tournament
his biggest single tournament success to
date still he lost one game against
Magnus garden and in fact it is that the
sim is a terrible matchup for Nakamura
he's got an amazingly bad score against
cars and tournament chess he hasn't won
a single game and lost who seven or
eight games like I needed to look it up
678 something like that real
considerable amount of games and he
never won a single one the only one in
bits and and wrap it of course but never
in tournament chess so um somehow both
players are styles don't do a fit
together low for the camera um yeah so
let's have a look at this game in the
last video that I showed her with a
cousin game it was focused on Cal's less
being a defender and now we see an
attacking game so we have fo and it's in
fact the the open Sicilian and the night
off again at already already shown a
couple of night offs here and again it's
Bishop e2 cuz usually prefers this line
but now the camera place if I've ahead
the game calls against crucial before
Legree shock played e6 and transferred
into the given against Kevin again hey
villain and yeah something like that and
now we five so it's a pure night off 93
Bishop e7 and here it's an interesting
moment of the skin on the by far the
most common move he s just just castles
and then black usually castles himself
after which white has a choice he has
some many options you can then player
moves like a form this should be 3f form
King edge one and so on but it's
important to note that castles is like
smooth after White Castle short but
causal plays Bishop e3 which might be
just transposition but after Nakamura
castles and here i think played this
rather quickly we see that Bishop e3
indeed has a point as cars and now does
not cancel which would just be a
transposition but now we place the move
g4 an interesting idea try to
immediately attack the knight on f6 and
it's very important this move is played
in a situation where black cannot play
d65 as it simply gives up a pawn um the
important thing is or the point is if
black wouldn't have castles but played
Bishop e6 just switching move orders
then g4 could have been answered with d5
so it's possible that this already
castles is some
slightly inaccurate as now g4 seems to
be an interesting line for white there
should be six I think this this makes
make sense to get this retreat square I
mean okay the view had to retreat square
anywhere about you anyway but you want
the bishop I guess developed here and
now aged form so white quickly has
gained space on the King side and you
will of course Castle long after a
subsequent Queen d2 a very important
point is that white has not moved the
f-bomb quite often for g4 h4 to be
possible you have played f3 first to
prepare g4 but here this was not
necessary so wyd in fact can play
without the earth porn or use the f porn
to move it just directly to f4 and we
see in the game that this is an
important idea on I think all right I
already prefer white here but it's not
it shouldn't be a fatal position for
black this is a this would be too much
but I think this is a really poisonous
idea that white players should look
should should have a look at this should
be three is interesting the only bill
should be three okay now h4s plate and
yeah what should like do it some very
critical already because wider what
hasn't wasted any time on the King side
and you really need to make sure that
you have some yeah some counter play
going what are possible ideas um one
idea could be knight c6 here just
developing this piece and after let's
say Queen d2
preparing long castles black could
strive the interesting with a five if
I've always looks a bit strange and the
night off because it just weakens b5 and
after all you play very often play a six
to do there be five instead but a five
has a very concrete ideas just very
simple a5 a4 would push the night back
and for example if black is white snow
castles long then that a form would send
the night to the terrible square a 1 so
a 5 is just a move to prevent long
castles here um y term will probably
answer with them with a fall and then
black has gained the square before for
this night which is an important point
it always at XC 2 & a 4 is not a move
you love to make if you intend long
castles so it's quite interesting to to
examine this pawn push in fact instead
of knight c6 here a 5 is also a possible
move that black and tribe he however in
comparison to 96 first the Queen has not
moved which is the slight difference
white for example can think of f4 here
after this and no a for white has gained
the default square this is in fact one
key idea of this F forms that white
removes the fight spawn from his post
and allows the night on b3 to use the
default square in the whole night of
blacks positional compensation for the
weekend d 5 square quite often as the
badly placed night on v3 the night only
three really look at this it only looks
at squares that are easily defended by
black it doesn't detect anything and
quite often watch needs to spend some
time to regroup this piece there are
lines where white place maneuvers like
that to to get this night into play so a
5s a try to immediately use this or I
take this piece which is not too well
placed now Camera Raw ever ops to not
push any pawns on the queenside at all
and them I personally don't like that
plan too much I think you need some
points to to do to do any damage and the
long run on them on the queenside but
it's a valid solid plan it's not like em
this is unknown this idea but it seems
so less effective in the game Queen d2
now is played timing is essential if
white goes f4 immediately which is in
general part of the plan black can take
and can think of playing d5 and this is
something you don't really want to allow
its frees up some trees about blacks
position considerably so first Queen d2
which just prevents d5 due to this win
over pawn on it takes deep so night
developed and now air for as matching
the ideas remove this pawn to get the
night back into play yeah s white also
threatens to push the pawn FYI five it
done I'd steer the black
he needs to take not a lot much choice
and we captures yet 95 very young
logical using this square and cancelling
long yes how to assess this position I
really prefer white because this is such
an inviting room for the night there's
also the 95 idea of course while blacks
play is mostly centered about night to
see 489 20 and try to attack the king
with with pieces alone however receive
in the game that were the good
prophylactic moves it's questionable if
black really gets anything serious going
played rook c8 of course utilizing the
look on the CFR and King be one and I
need to get the King out of the sea file
and Queen system yep black really spends
quite a number of moves here to get
pieces out here night c4 was also
possibility and maybe a better mood and
so this kind of um continuation is a
similar to the game that black has not
played Queens this happen that doesn't
seem to be such an effective post for
the Queen yeah h5 need the pawns and
again probably not see for now as better
but then I camera played rook to e8 this
is a quite common move in the Sicilian 2
minus the mother of things as well to
prepare bishop f8 as a um yeah to
prepare bishop ave to safeguard the king
and now the next move is Sir
I think the best movement in the game
and it's a rather typical move from the
FL for cards and style he has some
played a number of attractive attacking
games in the past but those games are
very often paired with some fine
reflective prophylactic thinking where
besides on where instead of just yeah
attacking with all our possible force he
spent some just the right amount of time
on defensive measures so that quite
often these attacks are are not as
spectacular as some some others simply
because there's a little counter play
very often attractive detective
attacking chess ISM associated with
those kind of low counterblow moves like
one one side and sacrificing the others
to encounter sacrifice on and your own
king is in trouble and so on but this
yoke don't see so often and cons and
scams he quite often has his attracts so
nicely prepared that it looks like a
complete one-way street all right so
what move am I talking about he now
played very strong move king to a one he
spent two moves to get the King from see
1 2 A 1 and what exactly is this doing
yeah the main point is that the King on
a one is not exposed to check if the
night arrives on a 3 like to to show you
on a possible possible line um let's say
white wouldn't have played this and
played yeah
move like that which doesn't really do
much good just just to show check and
here's the check that i was talking
about and in this kind of position you
you cannot go to a one as this plunges
the Queen and yeah what what I going to
do now you don't really want to take it
this looks horrible it's probably not
fatal but not what wide wants to do but
with the King on a1a night on 83 is just
no check and this is a huge difference
after King a 1 i'm nakamura played the
bishop to evade but now 94 in comparison
is just much less effective let's say it
takes takes Queen Queen default my life
before was wasn't especially great this
move but just to show here black caviar
black could play night a three but what
exactly is this move doing it's not a
check so wyd can just easily continue
with this his old play and this is just
just a very strong maneuver getting the
King to a one it's a very good
productive prophylactic thinking and
this very much leads to a very one-sided
game just a couple of moves later it's a
in fact not so easy to say at which
exact point now camera's position drifts
from being just critical to to being
lost I mean from a practical point of
view it's it's already very very tricky
let's let's see some more moves that
look completely logical bishop of ADA's
managed as mentioned 94 now this night
gets back into play and this is so
important the night can go to f5 which
is an excellent attacking post and if
you play g6 you open up the H file so
having g6 black I mean
would open up the the H file and not
really not really helps much white still
has a very strong attack um in fact
something like this already is decisive
I'm sorry so Quincy five I was played
probably getting this at the end to the
mix or queen to a five and our g6 strong
move but compared to King a1 not
especially difficult I mean what else
why just needs to open up the position
this is attacking chess one-on-one so to
say what King a1 is really a high-class
move so what did nakamura play play
tonight c4 try to get something against
the King just capturing on on g6 doesn't
really save I mean something like that
and now let's say h6 can be again
answered like that not good this one is
also absolutely horrible it's just an
amazingly dangerous attack coming
something like that this is also on
black guy cannot defend this position he
played nazi form understandable why took
it when to Queen d3 and again note the
King on a one if just put put this
position on the board with the King on
b1 and it's a different story um just
for argument's sake here this doesn't
make any sense i just want to show with
the King on b1 this is just irritating
move what I
doing if you play King a wonders queen
deform and it's all turned around so the
King on a one is just just very nicely
placed it helps to to defend costs King
Etch A to C useless move I was just want
I just wanted to show the difference so
um yeah what what did nakamura play he
took on g6 you could try to defend with
h6 not opening um so many lines but
after that it's still an excellent
position for white he for instance could
swing the Queen over to g3 and increase
some the pressure even further so it
doesn't really give like much relief he
took recaptured and h6 try to keep the
position yeah closed some as long as
possible Queen g3 understandable swing
the Queen toward some on the king and
another idea is of course this capture
which is happen and we will quite soon
it go come to the point where this is a
very valid line I'm here black plate
Queen B 6 threatening on b2 and now just
Bishop to see water safely protecting
the poor and after that concentrating on
the on the attacking efforts note that
this is perfectly safe this is the check
at any point at any point b 2 is
protected and in this position after
Queen B 6 in fact white also could have
considered b3 and in fact the computer
gives this is very strong and probably
winning however it's just not a very
human
and Carlton despite being an excellent
calculator on place at times very human
chess very logical understandable moves
you don't want to weaken you on your
King side and Bishop c1 is just simple
and good it keeps this night stable and
not moving any points is giving White's
King I'm the best possible security and
safety and white still has the strong
attack I mean night here night here
takes a 95 and so on the nights are just
ready to roll towards the king while
this bishop alone defends her the whole
King position yeah Queenie 54 stride try
to maybe get this into the game but it's
already it's already too late look D to
F 1 further improving yeah all pieces
here are nicely placed they all there
already of course was this option just
playing directly for this d 5 square
also very strong the computer calculates
this to a flat out win already for white
but why hurry like is not exactly going
anywhere you can just pile up pressure
and this eases the tasks in the long run
95 trying to use the night for defense
and also threatening something made on a
two so 95 just blocking that like had no
choice he needed to take the night and
get here the combined attacking ideas
are not not defensible any more like has
some only M has some some tries to to
put up some resistance but objectively
it's already lost he grabbed the pawn on
d5 and yeah now it's time to strike if
you have some time on your hands then
you could um stop the video here and try
to calculate the coming becoming
sequence it's not especially difficult
but it's a good calculation exercise if
you try to really i calculate this to
the end so I'm going to pause just a
couple of seconds so that you can also
hit pause yourself in the video right
it's not difficult as mentioned but it's
a good calculation exercise the
rightness of course is Bishop takes h6
you need to break through here
everything's ready for a sacrificial
attack all pieces are nicely placed this
night is also close so what else um is
there to improve it's time to strike so
I'm get this is a flat-out will nakamura
grabbed it understandably if you check
the alternatives queen takes this easily
answered by Bishop e3 which introduces
this idea to give me a check made let's
say something like that check check
check nate is the typical mate so Queen
takes d4 is not not on at all I can try
to attack the g6 born but after the
simple retreat those lines are just are
just wide open and
this is just just completely deadly
neither 72 to cover it yeah and now we
are approaching force mates yeah black
took it it's understandable just take
the piece and now the point which you
already expect I guess is g7 just
breaking through him black moves the
bishop then Luke takes h6 introduces
this immediate made thread and there's
some there's no defense to that and this
in fact was post played in the game we
can briefly check the capture after
night f5 threatening on g7 there's
simply no new moves that like and play
something like look here check check
also check needs to fatal material
losses and made us not far away so this
was played at night f7 yan term here's
someone spot where good calculation on
move 29 with visual range six is
necessary of course it just looks like
there should be should be something but
you still need to calculate it properly
and there's one straight winning line 26
note that check this which looks very
very dangerous is not on because check
check this is a counter meet the Queen
on d5 protects a or God's the h1 square
so we don't have the maid but Queen g6
however is strong and not
difficult to to calculate black needs to
take this is just too big a threat takes
and just recaptures and the threaten
screen 2 h8 mate which means that black
only has one move to prevent an
immediate loss I mean okay this also
lose immediately but to drag on a bit
and here check them the final strokes
are Queen h8 King moves check jaw just
promoting okay to take here and now
after King e8 their sake one check and
telecom we are resigned in view of King
b7 and crank nate e7 mate so a nice
attacking win and a completely clean
game Carlton really didn't make any any
mistake in at one point or another while
executing the yeah not really executing
the tech but um well being in a good
position he could have played in fact
more computer ish moves but he preferred
to get to play human prophylactic girl
moves to make sure that black has no
counter play against whites King and
after that after he really got rid of
more black some counter threats then the
tech was really yeah just flowing easily
Bishop h6 g7 night f5 all this wasn't
really difficult the difficult part of
games like that ah moves like that one
King a one that really make sure that
the counter play is is reduced
considerably so this is a really typical
attacking game by Carlton it's it it
leaves this impression of being yeah an
easy game I like
what special moves did you do I mean
just calculating one or two sacrifices
this is not too difficult at some point
it just is a natural and relatively
simple to play flow but to get to that
um really needs a excellent preparation
moves like the Sun King a one move it
really impressed me back then because um
when I when I watched the game i know
that i watch this in the evening i think
and i was really thinking hmm why isn't
this such an easy looking win and
afterwards when some commentators looked
at the game they really pointed out that
King a one is the storm fear of this of
this game all right I hope you enjoyed
this game I'll be back tomorrow with
another game by wall champion vishy
anand thanks for watching